okay so here we are I'm going to attempt
to make Japanese dish called Oh Moo rice
ooh what would I say Oh would I sue
particular guide in Kyoto called chef
mojo kiichi Yukimura and he does his the
best that probably anybody does it doing
lots of chef's tricks he makes this
really perfect omelet that's like a
total cylinder that's really gooey in
the middle
he lays it on top and then he cuts it
with a knife and it unfolds like an
alien's stomach then he pours gravy on
top and it looks really awesome the
co-worker Adam asked if I could just try
to recreate it I think it's a pretty
good challenge I do not claim to be good
at cooking in any way disclaimer I was
challenged to do this do not edit that
out
cool now it's time to take this thing
the chef in the video has an oval-shaped
mold I don't know where you got those
we're just gonna go with a round one we
have a bunch of this sticky fried rice
action I'm gonna do something like this
what pash and then I think I'm just
gonna leave it like that until it's the
time burner got this pan into the right
pan we're gonna find out I think I'm
gonna go with about three eggs to start
yeah I'm specifically hiding the egg
cracking action oh [ __ ] we got a double
yolk I just had a double yolk good luck
right slightly too much egg here
terrible this is a disaster
alright definitely too many eggs for the
size of pan I mean what you have here is
a bunch of overcooked eggs with a bunch
of undercooked eggs on top yeah here's
what I'm gonna do someone's always
hungry I'm just going to offer a
scrambled eggs one of my co-workers
wonder how many years that guy practice
his craft
be right back hey do you want these eggs
hmm do you want these eggs okay attempt
two and we're back we're gonna try it
my preferred silicone spatula you know
what else just in case I do it perfectly
this time I should make sure that this
rice mold oh yeah okay lower the heat
are there enough eggs here I didn't
really make the curds evenly but that
was on top of a pile of rice and it was
made perfectly then yeah that would look
like what we're trying to achieve great
we're getting somewhere
[Music]
until we overdone I stirred it one round
to him any time I think I think I'm
gonna go back to using the chopsticks
because when I'm using the spatula and
I'm pushing the eggs around I'm making
curds as large as the leading edge of
the spatula whereas if I do it with this
it's like I've got two pool cues that
I'm making my curds with much smaller
that should make it better to roll I
think maybe
how does he how does he
[Music]
it's like in Mario when we make a really
hard jump and you're like oh the rest of
this level just gets harder using a
different pan because that was obviously
the problem this one is maybe a little
bit more slippery and it has kind of a
more generous curve to it
oh yeah we're cooking with eggs now okay
I definitely already cooked it too much
kind of smells like dog hair okay just
get right back into it I don't know
where we are in video run time lens
we've been here for like three hours now
I'm running out of people to feed eggs
to also I got it's slipping off the pan
let me get got this well it's on there
little craggily but the overall shape is
feeling good nice enough so that can go
like that I cut a little bit too deep
sort of so we're down to the last three
eggs from every a watch my last attempt
whether it's good or bad the last one
was pretty good it made it on the rice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now hopefully it's not too done in the
center and when I go
[Music]
not really well but I know how hard it
is now we got the texture right yeah I
don't think I did
then you'd be creamier
[Music]
really I got oh that's it I mean look I
didn't expect to perfect a master's dish
in one afternoon now that video is just
that much better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]